on YouTube welcome everyone I'm just
kind of starting us over here because we
are starting our recording that will go
onto YouTube thanks for attending live
or those of you watching this recorded
thank you for watching I am going to put
my presentation up today we're talking
about optimizing the Udacity career
services and I know when you when you're
joining the your nano degree and it's
there's a lot of information and you
really want to get started in your class
and then the content that you wanting to
learn so sometimes those career services
can be the back of your mind and also
you might start the program not thinking
of needing any career changes you're
just doing it for personal development
and maybe your situation changes anyway
we want to make sure you know all of the
resources available to you so that you
can optimize those services then about
halfway through will spend about 30
minutes on that then the next 30 minutes
we're gonna be doing speed networking
and if you have attended before it's a
lot of fun we put you in breakout rooms
we've switched pretty quickly every few
minutes you get to know some of you the
other Udacity students Brett the other
coach and I will try to also pop in some
of the rooms as much as possible and
hopefully you'll get to meet some new
people from all around the world also
taking a Udacity course
tiny bit about myself I'm a career coach
here with Udacity I'm also a corporate
trainer I do a lot in communication
skills presentation skills a lot of team
building and things around career
development I've lived and worked in
America Australia China and Singapore
and my background is started in finance
did some consulting international
business and now I'm based here in
Chicago
one thing I wanted to do to get ready
for our speed networking and don't type
this in the chat box but I want you to
think of one eunuch
unique fact about yourself think about
what it's going to be write it down on a
piece of paper don't share it and think
about what that unique fact is now
remember if you're taking your destiny
course that is not unique in this
scenario right here unique could be
maybe you met someone famous you've
traveled to someplace very interesting
anything that you can think of that's
just a little bit unique about yourself
because you're going to share that later
in our speed networking event if you're
not sure yet that's okay we're going to
come back to this in a little while so
for those of you still joining in
just writing down a unique fact about
ourselves again don't type it into chat
just keep it to yourself for now and
we're going to come back to this in
about a half hour when we get ready for
our speed networking
so let's jump into Career Services the
first step that had to kind of find
everything we're gonna talk about today
is finding the career portable so I've
got a screenshot of my Udacity classroom
up there that probably looks very
similar to most of yours and you see the
little briefcase I've got the yellow
arrow pointing to that's the career
portal and that is where you will find
almost all of the career services that I
talked about today so if you're just
getting ready to get out there and
explore find that career portal now
quickly at a glance I'm gonna walk
through all of the career services and
then we're gonna come we're gonna go
back into a few several of these in a
little more detail to make sure you
understand what's available to you so
again that we want you to optimize all
the services that you are allocated
first you have four career projects
LinkedIn resume cover letter is included
for all nanodegrees github is on many
but not all some people it's not as
relevant you get one to one career
coaching and we'll talk about that a
little more detail you have the careers
channel in the student hub we've got
career focused webinars like today
workshops that are always done via zoom
and then we've got the YouTube library
of recorded career events that we will
share that link with you as well so if
you want to go back and look at topics
we've discussed in the past that's a
great resource you also have the ability
to have your personal profile updated in
the Udacity talent program so that our
partner companies can look for
candidates and find you there
then of course we've just got extensive
tips and advice in our blog and in
different places throughout the Udacity
website that will make sure you're
familiar with so that's an overview at a
glance all the services now let's go
into a little detail of each of those so
you know what is available to you yes
this one have a question
Seifer voice yes I think maybe someone
just was accidentally I muted okay
let's talk about the career projects the
career projects are essentially
tutorials with reviewer feedback when
you go to do your career projects again
its resume LinkedIn cover letter and
github it'll say submit project and
that's kind of starts the tutorial
there's videos a lot of different tips
and some reading that you can do to make
sure that you're ready to put together
the best possible resume LinkedIn cover
letter and github then at the end of the
project you'll hit submit it goes to one
of our reviewers it comes back to you
kind of using your rubrics typically you
get that back within 24 to 48 hours and
it's some really valuable feedback that
you can use to improve your application
materials you have access to these
unlimited for up to 12 months following
your graduation so if I graduated today
I have access to those for a year
something to mention one is if if you
don't graduate if you drop out of the
program obviously you you lose these
this access also in some nano degrees
you will see that for instance github is
a required project or LinkedIn sometimes
they are required to finish your nano
degree so you need to make sure you do
those during your nano degree if you've
got some circumstance where you can't
finish it and you need to finish the
nano degree you can write into career
support and asks that that be waived you
don't want to just there's that they'll
give you an option that says you just
want it to go away and you're not going
to do it but then you lose all access to
career services and I highly recommend
you don't do that so at the worst case
just just go through the tutorial submit
what you've got it does not go into her
so if you've done a resume that your leg
and I don't love it but I still would
like to get some feedback I'm getting
there it's a work in process submit it
for review it's not going to go on our
portal it's not going to go to any
employers it's just feedback with that
one reviewer so it does not have to be
in perfect condition
to submit so just keep that in mind if
it's if it's kind of the best you're at
right now that's okay does not have to
be perfect to submit Brett is there
anything that you would add to career
projects at this stage uh yeah the only
thing I would add is when it relates to
the feedback is that you're going to get
kind of general feedback so almost like
what they would what you might hear from
like an actual recruiter or a hiring
manager so it's not going to say like
you spelled this word wrong or the
grammar here is incorrect it's more
going to be like bigger picture things
like it would be helpful for you to
include something like this or have you
thought about including your project
something like that it's not going to be
as you know critical and so I usually
recommend that people complete these
career projects before they sign up for
one-on-one coaching sessions with us
about those specific things so if you
want help with your resume I recommend
doing the career project first getting
that you know going through those
tutorials making updates submitting it
for feedback then making continued
revisions and then signing up for a
coaching call with one of us so we can
be a little bit more intentional and
make the most out of your coaching calls
yeah that's a great point and and if you
have a current a coaching session on it
maybe you're talking about interviewing
or other topics don't hesitate to sign
up but if you want to talk about your
resume it's definitely best to come in
with your best possible version of your
resume that you've got have gotten to so
like Brett said do the project first so
you you know you're coming to the coach
with hey I think I'm in pretty good
shape but can you help me let's
fine-tune it let's refine it get it even
better to them and maybe we can even
help you if you've got a job you know
you want to apply for we can help look
at it and say okay is this resume really
best positioning you for this role so
any questions about career projects at
this stage feel free to type it in or
unmute yourself
any questions does the twelve-month
o'clock on Career Services gets reset
with subsequent nanodegrees Lea that is
such a good question I've had people ask
me when they get into a new nano degree
do they get all the a whole nother like
batch of services again Brett do you
know the exact answer to that so I know
if you let's say for example you sign up
for one nano degree program and then you
sign up for an additional one without
taking part in anything you're going to
get an additional four coaching session
so with each nano degree program that
you sign up for you get four coaching
sessions depending on how you pay for
them is how they will be unlocked so if
you pay for them bimonthly you'll get
those unlocked each month that you pay
for them but if you do sign up for two
nano degrees then you'll have a total of
eight coaching sessions but as far as
like the the clock reset I'm assuming
that like your coaching sessions would
expire for one of them after 12 months
of completing the first one so I'm not
that like that's kind of a tricky
situation I think if you that's
definitely gonna be like case-by-case
basis depending on like when you signed
up for one or the other but I do know
that you get an additional set of
coaching sessions specifically for each
nano degree program that you sign up for
everything else is kind of like you
would probably want to redo because if
you're doing one nano degree program for
data analysts but then you want to do
something from machine learning your
resume and Linkedin should in your cover
letter all that should look somewhat
different so I would recommend kind of
going through that process again okay
great thank you yeah and and as we go
through some of these services and like
Brett mentioned a little bit it is going
to vary based on your nano degree and
how you pay if you're on the
subscription if you finish something
early so there is a little bit of it's
not totally black and white that
everyone gets so many of coaching
sessions which we'll get to in a minute
will give you the best information that
applies to everyone today if you have a
specific if you want to know exactly
what your allocated and what it is it's
always best and Brett if you can type
our support email in there for career
support to email career support and say
I know how many I have of this and they
can help you get your specific
information
alright now let's talk about career
coaching again my little Asterix at the
bottom it can vary by degree term and
payment plan but generally speaking
people are gonna crew up to four
coaching sessions so these four coaching
sessions are 30-minute sessions via
phone and why don't we just get a little
pull here for you can type in the chat
box have you had a coaching session yes
or no I'd love to know how many on here
have had a coaching session so what
happens is you will go in to the career
portal you will book your career
coaching session with one of the coaches
you get to pick you could choose the
same coach every time you could switch
around get different perspectives it's
completely up to you and you know
there's a little bio on each coach you
can see if they have some something in
their background that interests you or
where they're located really is all up
to you and we've got a nice selection of
coaches that I think that you'd be happy
with again you can get up to four
coaching sessions they will call you for
a 30-minute session on the phone if the
phone is difficult for you if you get
bad reception whatever it is you can
always put in yours when you submit for
your session please could I have a zoom
meeting for this appointment and we can
do that as well
again you get these sessions for up to
12 months following your graduation and
again if you if you don't graduate if
you stop the nanodegree you you do lose
these sessions so let's take a look at
our coaching panel so again we've got
Brett the top everything everyone on the
top is I'm gonna I was gonna tell you
the location of everyone but now I'm
kind of forgetting where everyone is I
would say a lot in North America Meera's
in India Jaclyn is in the UK everyone
else is North America how's that for
narrowing it down but we've got so
basically we've got a lot of time zones
so that is nice to help you we open up
our calendars three to four weeks in
advance so you can get on there you can
see availability
if you book a session and realize oh my
gosh I have an interview coming up that
day or I've got this important meeting
at work just go back in the portal
cancel it and then it will allow you to
reschedule but some people think if they
just decline the meeting and their
calendar it's going to go away but that
actually doesn't do it you need to go
back into the portal and cancel and
another little thing to know if you want
to reschedule your time at all so just
emailing the coach and saying hey could
we just push this so tomorrow is really
hard a lot of us we've got pretty packed
calendars through not only Udacity but
other work we do as well so best cases
if you can't make that meeting just
cancel it and then reschedule for
another time same coach or different
coach and really like I would say the
most productive coaches some people ask
you know what's the best way to go into
the coaching session to make them most
of my time and I would say you know if
you know what you want to talk about if
you have if it's an interview if it's
something about your resume any
information you can give us is great if
you're at a stage where you're like you
know I don't even know where to start
I just need to talk to someone that's
okay too we will help you at whatever
stage you're at we're gonna help you
continue to progress on the path and get
you create a path or help you along that
path where you're headed so don't feel
like you have to be super prepared but
if you do have something you want to
talk about let us know that when you sit
when you put in your appointment you
have space there to type some things out
give us some information give us your
Linkedin address those kind of things
help us make the appointment even more
productive but also don't feel like you
have to have something prepared I have a
lot of meetings for people just don't
know where to start and they just want
to start the conversation and that's
okay and we make it happen so that's a
little summary of your career coaching
any questions on Career Coaching Angela
can I add something yes absolutely
just to kind of help people understand
just a little bit about what things we
can coach on one of the things they keep
in mind is that I don't think that any
of our coaches are by any means
technical experts so a lot of us are
coming from backgrounds within like
leadership HR education we're not coming
from you know programming and web
development backgrounds and so we're not
gonna be the best resources as it
relates to your nano degree program or
things like technical interviews or very
in-depth knowledge of the industries
that you're in so we also and then
another thing to consider is that you
know a lot of us are you know based in
certain geographic locations so we can't
possibly be experts on the hiring
standards across the world so there is
going to be a certain level of things
that that you should be aware of as well
so you know if you aren't based in the
US but you're signing up for a us-based
coach you should still be bringing a
certain level of understanding of what
you know are the common hiring practices
but then also know that if you have
questions regarding your nano degree or
specific technical questions that recur
that are related to your nano degree you
have a nano degree mentor that can be a
great resource for you in that aspect
yeah that's great I always tell people
come with any questions but if it's a
sensor fusion or Python I'm not gonna be
able to help you so just kind of keep
that in mind and and we the thing that I
find that's really right I think is
pretty exciting for Udacity students is
that because we talked to such a great
volume of students and so many of you
across different nano degrees I feel
like what I also I feel like we're a
resource of information on ideas on
where to look for jobs and companies
hiring and we hear a lot by talking to
so many of you so I think that you know
we have a lot of insight into what's
happening in different fields and and
who's hiring and how other people have
had success and sharing success stories
to help you as well and I know that I've
had several occasions where I've been
able to kind of connect
Udacity students in different countries
are in the same country a couple were in
Italy and they were getting together to
meet to kind of trade notes and talk
about some things so that's kind of
exciting as well and Tiago has a
question and I'm going to get to that in
just a minute just in a couple slides on
regarding the programs for partnerships
next thing I want you to know about is
the Udacity student hub most of you have
probably already gotten on there you see
on again this is my screenshot you see
the little purple bubble and so one
thing I will say there is if you've
enrolled it like in the last two weeks
your screen might look a little bit
different and it might be called the
student chat so student hub student chat
should still be the same little purple
icon it's the online chat where you're
gonna find the link of your classroom
your mentor will be on there so you're
gonna be very active in that you'll also
see a channel that is careers and we
have seven slots seven times a week when
each coach will be on there with live
answers also anytime we get on we also
go back and see if there's any questions
that have not been answered so I would
say you're definitely gonna have your
question answered you know during Monday
through Friday within 24 hours
easy if it's over the weekend it might
be a little bit longer but you can see
again where I've pointed that up to my
careers channel so if you get on there
any if you wake up in the middle of the
night you're like I have a question
about my resume or my interview tomorrow
type it in there one of us will get to
you as soon as possible and again we've
got live coaches online I'll show you
how to see what times those are that if
you want some back and forth and have a
couple questions you could find those
times as well so that's a really great
resource and we love when we're on there
live we love when there's questions I
don't know about you Brett when I get on
there and there's no questions I tend to
start doing something else and then I'm
like whoa I've got to get back on so ask
us questions keep us busy
career events obviously you know how to
find those you're here right now these
are our live webinars and workshops and
we're gonna get to our workshop in the
next 10 minutes I do want to make sure
we we have time for that you register on
the events page I'm guessing most of you
did that and again you can watch those
recorded events on YouTube I will show
you here and when I get to the end of
this content a list of all the resources
that where you can go to find everything
I've talked about today I'm going to
address some of the questions coming up
in the chat right now
someone said they think they're
nanodegree doesn't have a student hub I
think that would be a great question if
you could ask the Career Services
because I think everyone should but
maybe there's an exception I'm not aware
of what does it mean if careers is not
listed under communities
you should everyone should automatically
have careers listed if for some reason
you do not please again email career
support and tell them you cannot see
that I think there was a bug with a few
of the Nano degrees and we want to make
sure you can get on there and Brett said
when you go to the classroom try
clicking in a help icon and you should
have more options for the chat it's
great yeah they've changed I think they
changed the user interface just a little
bit and so in it used to show up like
that icon that you showed I'm gonna show
up as like the bubble with the chat but
now sometimes when you're in that
classroom you can access your nano
degree but if you click that help icon
it'll give you access to like four
different things and one of them is like
peer chat then you have career services
there as well if yours has changed or if
you have signed up for something you
know a more recent program it might be
there so if you want to whoever has
questions about that try that and then
if you if you're not having if you don't
see that then you can kind of keep
asking in the chat and I'll pay
attention to it Thanks okay you
udacity profile this is where once you
graduate you want to make sure all of
your information is current you're
you've got your by this point hopefully
you've had your coaching sessions you've
done your career projects so your resume
is ready to go your LinkedIn link is
ready so that when you graduate you're
uploading and everything is up to date
so that you're searchable in the Udacity
talent database people ask all the time
do they get jobs it's it is not a job it
there's not often a job board where you
can go in and search but our partner
companies can go in and find people so
it is a great place to make sure you are
searchable and and to have your
information in there it's also I will
mention at this time I think is a good
time to mention it's also really helpful
to put your Udacity degree in the
education section of LinkedIn and
there's a few different reasons for that
one is gonna allow you to be in the
LinkedIn Udacity alumni group that you
can request to be in and they need to
see that in there also you should have
your certificate in the license and
certificates part of LinkedIn also if
you want to network with other Udacity
students who have taken the same nano
degree weather virtually or in person
you can find those people as well by a
by being able to search you go into the
Udacity LinkedIn page click on alumni
and you're gonna find everyone who has
Udacity in their education section so
it's a really valuable tool for
networking and contacting with people
someone mentioned the scholarships
that's a good point but there are
different scholarships that come out and
be based on those different scholarships
different services are available or not
and again we're not aware of every
single scholarship out there and so if
you have questions about your
scholarship talk to your mentor or again
email Career Services and I'm a ha I'm
sorry to keep throwing you to email
career services but I don't want to give
you bad information I just want to make
sure today we talk about like as an
umbrella general population this is what
you all get but I know there are some
differences on with different people
okay and then there's more and this is
again a screenshot I'm trying to get
this a little more easily accessible
through this the student from your
career portal right now that the address
you see there at the top curb Resources
Center at dot udacity.com is the best
place to go to it again I'm gonna give
you a list of all these resources in a
minute this is where you can there's
just a wealth of information on this
part of the blog where you can find out
information on interview tips on other
resume advice work opportunities so this
is a great place to get even more
information okay here are your Quick
Links they don't look so quick do they
they're a little detailed I will make
sure that this gets this slide gets sent
out to all of you individually so that
you have these all these exact links
again career portal I think we all know
where that is that's that little
briefcase the student hub careers
channel that's going to be either that
little purple icon I showed you or a
help icon we've got the webinars and
workshops schedule that's Udacity events
recorded events that's our YouTube
channel the Career Resource Center which
is I would I consider a little bit like
a blog and just a bunch of information
that you can access and then the last is
your personal profile upload which
remember you cannot do until you have
graduated
all right now one thing I could try
really quick I'm going to stop sharing
and see if I can just copy and paste all
of those which would be way easier for
all of you to have this immediately and
put that in the chat so while I'm doing
that I know there's a lot of information
hopefully it gives you a better feel and
handle on what's available
let's do about five minutes of questions
if there are any and then we will go
into our speed networking which is super
fun
all right so the links I think are gonna
come in now into the chat yes and
actually they pasted quite well so all
of those links are now in the chat for
you all right let's go to questions feel
free to unmute yourself turn on your
video talk if you want or just type it's
totally up to you
um
someone said that maybe they didn't have
access to the student have due to the
scholarship yeah so so yeah honey and
I'm sorry about that if you can maybe
check with the leader of that program
you could probably get more specific
information on that
other questions other questions about
career services I'm going to put the
list of services up there that at a
glance to just remind you of everything
that we mentioned
and let me just get up there in one
second and see if there's any other
questions
you
there we go there are your career career
services at a glance remember you get
your projects your coaching you get that
chat that careers channel which might be
called peer chat it could be called the
careers Channel and the student hub will
all be on one name here soon
we've got the webinars and workshops got
the YouTube library your personal
profile and then that big resource of
all those tips and advice
someone said to get the most out of
career services is there anything else
we can prepare besides the four projects
out of your coaching you know I think
just thinking about questions you might
have you know before you just like you
would any meeting or interview before
you have your coaching session you know
think about make a list of some
questions that are on your mind and you
know kind of keep that little running
list of what's really on your mind or
concerning you and again you don't have
to have all four of those projects done
before you meet with us you don't have
to have any of them done but if you want
to talk about your cover letter talk
about your resume it is better to have
done that project before having the
meeting on that topic
all right okay so for everyone who's
watching this recorded the recording is
going to stop because we are going to go
into our net speed networking event and
that's really difficult not so exciting
to watch as a recorded video so at this
point I am going to say thank you for
watching those of you who are watching
this recorded and for the rest of you
please stay on for those of you live
stay on because we're going to get
started